okay let's do the usual from beautiful
Mac or PC Mac of course I use a PC I use
a Mac quite a lot at the time I do have
I possess some pcs oh it's got to be PC
definitely for Derrick we call him he's
also known as Mac its Mac not a PC go
mad for that night for Mac of PC Mac or
PC Mac Linux Mac PC Linux I've gone very
much as you can see I probably prefer a
Mac but I've got a PC Mac um I use
Windows
whichever's were appropriate I do Mac
now PC Mac or PC or Chromebook Niva
Linux man at the moment it is still for
me PC plus Linux but at some vague stage
in the near future I make a pitch late
and go for a fully Mac solution in the
course of doing these videos for you
I've seen people catch sight of an apple
on what they think is my desk well I
have to say sadly it's not mine it
belongs to my colleague because we share
this room and he's not in very often but
when he is he uses the Apple Macintosh
and yet I've also confused you totally
by referring to the fattest I run open
Susie and I also have a straightforward
Windows 7 PC I use Windows which is a
fairly controversial decision amongst my
friends but there is not a Mac laptop
that actually does what I want it to
there's not a Mac laptop with a
significant enough graphics card that
will work and no decent video editing
software on lettuce so I have been
preaching for years that one should be
using the same machine that and the
people actually produce the machine they
also produce the software so they are
compatible and meanwhile I was using
Windows on a Dale and one day I decided
that I was in it was enough of crashes
and my blackberry not communicating with
Billa
that's it I moved to Mac and we're all
done
PC because we've got lots of them
further apart from Steven Stevens a real
Mac firm Mac most the time at the moment
yeah any reason for them at the time
good form factor for the hardware pretty
well made
the software is no more exasperated and
PC software so having done the Mac and
more about the Mac age 30 years and so
on I have to say there's still not my
first choice
they weren't back in the eighties but
let's try and offend everybody or let's
try and modify everybody had I been a
graphic designer and not a computer
scientist I would certainly have gone
for a Mac because all of the things that
matter to graphic designers worked
really really well and they were
designed for the Mac first of all and it
shows in everything they do
I'm the only one in the office that uses
the apples and I get slated for it so
they're all Windows guys around here
I've always used a PC and Apple are very
expensive and they have a rather
draconian warranty system good sir I'd
like to avoid just I can't afford a Mac
for one thing its historical I've been
on a PC for many many millennium I think
the problem for real computer scientists
was the Macintosh was good but it was
single user it was her graphic designers
it didn't participate in the world and
networked UNIX machines um Linux well
know whatever architecture any
architecture of a lot of text editor
cover on a massive Google fanboy and
other than that I like that it's the
nicest Linux PC you can get I'm max
these days
execution yeah first I was Linux and
then I found too much hassle installing
to sound drivers and whatever and
updating operating systems that I moved
to make but I've just always had these
pcs and you know I'm not like
it smacks particularly but yeah pcs no
I'm was a bit annoyed was Megan was
there copyright policy and digital theft
I calls us in the Macintosh didn't
participate in the world of networked
UNIX machines until relatively late on
and as many of you know that came about
Steve Jobs forming next next was built
on a unix-like system and so now that
it's come full circle Steve Jobs came
back to Apple brought this UNIX type
system with him then all of a sudden yes
now I could live on a Mac quite happily
and colleague Steve is an absolute
raving Mac enthusiast for just that
reason although other computers is
totally UNIX based you can have the best
of both worlds you can have the graphic
richness you can have a unix-like
environment as well
and that opening of fail would make
certain things happen on the hardware so
there's quite a long history of
different operating systems from the
very first inception you would have
different operating systems which would
run in different manufactures equipment
so IBM would have one anywhere would
have another and ICL would have another